welcome to this video playing Alfie 791
okay I'm in a bad streak here really
being down from 24 something to check to
the lower regions there that's not good
let's see if I can stop this yeah
heavily I owed rating my opponent your
child well that's not meaning much if
you play badly okay before it's rather
early I can take them but don't need to
just yet going to prepare a five anyway
so let's let's do that
I can take before now queen Quincy to
was kind of helpful and with the pawn
always the rook I don't know if it makes
a huge difference two points is two
pawns okay so we had to develop Knight
to c6 looks fairly natural in this
position that's another pawn and I'm
taking that as well okay might have
night maybe I just go back there right
out of any potential tactics like night
65 okay so what is he doing trying to
get a five I guess or a three I can't
play Knight to g5 them hmm
also like Bishop g4 I know maybe should
you fall I'm still kind of skeptical I
played really badly the last couple of
games so before I am blaming anything
substantial here I already want to have
this in the background so let's see my
knight on c6 I would like to play b5
here but it's not easy to do this
totally um yeah it makes my night in the
cubby five before like I'd say but it's
not it's not really working ok may push
this and prepare night before to keep it
on a to ya 94 is really helping me here
so see if I ever just keeping everything
nicely protected
okay white resign okay that's the end of
the street I could have played 93 and
that would have been better yeah okay
that wasn't a very exciting game but I'm
glad to have a heavy winnin yeah that
that looks quite normal everything but
yeah Queens Queens into here essentially
just blunders taking by the way is also
something that I'm not really a big fan
of because essentially you're trading a
better pawn for were spawned the d4 pawn
against the d6 porn why should probably
just castle which which makes it about
an equal position I think it's a bit too
tame wyd set up to play for an advantage
but after that i'm a little bit more
comfortable maybe already can thought
it's not clear what he does what you
should do now I move like b5 is really
ugly I'm giving me this controller yeah
but after after this I'm essentially
winning up getting getting two pawns and
a good position on top okay well the end
of this this bad streak thanks for
watching